- When I see people afraid of the rain,
I say, "Boy, you're afraid of life.".
There's so much more that I
could've done to push myself in
the direction of my dreams that I didn't.
You choose one thing, and
you dominate that one thing.
Do the thing you fear the most,
and fear will move out of the way.
Say, "Yes, I'm going to fail, yes,
this is not going to work out.
"Yes, this is going to
be a complete failure.".
Oh, I don't feel so good today.
Get your lazy, sick ass up out of bed.
Negative (beep) comes into my mind,
sometimes the weirdest (beep) things.
I really don't know why
this keeps popping up.
A life without challenge,
a life without pain,
is a life without growth.
I'm not the king of everything
if my health is not right.
My health is a priority.
Hey dude, (beep), I told
you to jump 20 years ago,
you still didn't jump, did you?
How do you feel about yourself?
- He's a professional
strongman and strength coach.
- He's known for his YouTube
fitness channel called
Strength Camp.
- He has a second popular
YouTube channel called
Elliot Said What.
- He's Elliot Hulse, and here are
his top 10 rules for success.
- When I see people
afraid of the rain, I say,
"Boy, you're afraid of life.
"That's really what you're scared of.
"you're scared of feeling your body.".
Each one of these is a
shock to my nervous system,
and then the wind comes and the
wind just freezes it upon my body.
I love the way this feels, man, I love it.
I want to feel life, that's
why I'm not afraid of pain,
that's why I'm not afraid to take risks.
Not because I'm courageous,
but because I'm crazy about life.
I love the way life feels on me,
I like the way it feels
when life's happening to me.
I don't necessarily always have
to be in control of life and
take it by the horns, I like
life to carry me around.
Shock me, I want life to
shock the (beep) out of me.
I want to feel it in each one of my pores.
In retrospect as an adult now
today, knowing what I know,
the experiences that I've
had and the technology that's
available to us, I realize that
I could've done a lot more.
There's so much more
that I could've done to
push myself in the direction
of my dreams that I didn't.
I held back, and even to this day,
I'm so regretful and
there's so much in me that
there's pain associated with
my not putting forth all the
effort that's associated
with reaching forward,
striving and achieving the deepest,
most powerful expression
of strength through me that
I dedicated my life to
supporting other people in
becoming the strongest
version of themselves.
There's absolutely no reason
on the face of the Earth that
you should not reach for every
bright star in your horizon.
Give everything that
you've got to be that,
because it's been given to you,
you're infused with that
inspiration for a reason.
Now I realize I didn't
reach the pentacle of
my performance when it came to football,
but I've been able to take
that and use the motivation,
use the feeling associated with
achieving that particular goal,
and direct it towards supporting
young guys coming up so
that they can reach their
goals, so that you can
become the strongest version of yourself.
My mistakes is a tool
for me to support you.
I'm reading a really
fascinating book right now
called The One Thing.
Can't remember the name
of the author right now,
but you can look it up on Amazon.
And this author asserts, and
I found this to be true in
my own experience and that's why
I find the book so fascinating.
He asserts that if you put all
of your eggs in one basket,
like Andrew Carnegie once
said, and just watch that
basket grow, you will reach
your greatest success.
That particularly means,
you choose one thing and
you dominate that one thing, and it will,
if you choose the right thing,
and we'll talk about it in a moment,
you choose the right one.
Or I've also heard it
described as or called the
keystone habit.
You choose the habit
that's associated with
dominating one thing, it will
inevitably trickle over into
other areas of your life.
You will see success in other areas if
you just dominate this one thing.
It's also been described
as the pareto principle,
or the 80/20 rule, whereby 80% of
your results will come
from 20% of your efforts.
The trick is to try to figure
out what is that 20% required?
Which one of these things do I hack at?
Put all my time, effort, energy, talent,
and faculty into dominating
so that it will have
a tremendous affect on everything else?
Do the thing you fear the most,
and fear will move out of the way.
It's always that thing that
you're not too sure about or
you fear that I often think is a
direction you should go into.
So I tell the young
people, and sometimes it's
irresponsible advice, but
it's just been my experience,
and Emerson Knowles might
say that, I should quote.
If you've got two choices about
where you want to go next,
and this is the well-trodden path.
In other words, it seems like it's stable,
it seems like there is
stability, safety, security in
this particular direction,
and this one is a mystery,
take the mystery, because you will never
regret taking action in the direction of
your dreams regardless
of what it gives you,
because the experience
always enhances you.
As opposed to taking
that well-trodden path,
living a life that truly isn't yours,
but was handed to you
or carved out for you.
Take the road less traveled.
You've got to failure,
because failure is the
soil that brings forth
the plants of success.
In other words, with every
failure is the seed for success.
You cannot succeed without failure in the
same way that a tree
cannot grow if you don't
bury the seed in the soil.
So be okay with it.
Say, "Yes, I'm going to
fail, yes this is not
"going to work out, yes this is
going to be a complete failure.".
I do this all the time, I put
up these videos sometimes and
I'm like,"Oh, that video
sucked, it was a failure.
"People aren't going to like it.".
But I do it anyway, because
I'm going to make another,
I'm going to make another one,
and I'm going to make another one,
and one of them is bound to be good.
So make more mistakes, make
more failures, keep going.
The idea is to shut your brain off,
because the thing is you're
neurotic and thinking too much.
Shut your brain off and just do it anyway.
Screw it up big time.
I tell this to people all the time.
If you're going up to a girl
that you'd like to speak to and
you've never done this before,
be prepared to (beep) the
whole thing up, be prepared
to do it completely wrong.
But be prepared to do it,
because you're going to learn
something from that failure.
You go and talk to her
and she's going to say,
"Get away from me, you loser.",
and you're going to say,
"Next time I should probably
pick my eyes up when
"I talk to her.".
You'll pick up a tip.
Then you'll do it again,
you'll pick up another tip,
pick up another tip.
The idea is that failure is your tool,
failure is the allusion towards being a
stronger version of yourself.
You've got to fail, embrace
failure, love failure.
Fail as many times as
you possibly can so that
you can get one step closer
to having the thing happen.
Oh I don't feel so good today.
Get your lazy, sick ass up out of bed.
The reason why you don't
feel so good today is because
you eating (beep).
Begin with a simple step.
Now it's a tough one
because it's all day long.
Going to school and passing test,
you'll set the appointment and make it.
Getting your foot fixed, set
the appointment and make it.
Diet, that's all day long.
Begin simple, my man.
Drink water.
Revolutionize your (beep)
life by drinking water.
Don't go crazy with all the
diet information out there.
There's 101 different diets and they all
contradict themselves and
if you follow this one,
and then two weeks later
you read a blog post or
you see a video about that one,
you get all this ADD bull(beep) going on.
Choose to drink water.
Say, "hey, I will drink
half my body weight in
"ounces of water a day.".
No matter what, it does not
matter if your choking on the
(beep) water, you filled
your belly up so much it's
going to burst, drink the water.
This requires a warrior
mindset and I think that's a
part of what's lacking.
It's interesting you know,
the more and more I read these
questions, the more and
more I meet you guys,
the more and more I'm realizing,
we aint got enough
warriors in this culture.
You guys are addicted lovers.
That's what I keep finding,
addicted lovers and
clever magicians.
And if you've been following my videos,
you know my metaphors.
Addicted lovers meaning like,
"Oh I love this, oh I'm
passionate about this,
"oh I love that", and it's like
I keep falling in love with
different things and you
never get anything done.
And the clever magician is a cynic who
holds everything at a distance.
"Well I know all about that.".
They're the best commenters here.
"Oh I know all about that,
he's wrong and I'm right.".
But you know what?
You're the guys who don't
try anything because
you're just sitting in your
dark caves wizarding about
different things and
thinking and reading and
flipping through your books.
"There's more information about stuff,
"I can't do anything yet,
I still have to learn.".
Where are the warriors that say,
"I'm going to make a decision
and I'm keeping it."?
Devotion, discipline, where's that?
Devote yourself to something bigger,
be decisive about what you're going to do.
Say, "I'm going to do it and that's it.",
and then be disciplined about getting it
done every single day, whether
you feel like it or not.
It's no poetic saying that you
become what you think about,
and that the world is your mirror.
We're literally creating
our world through the
thoughts that we harbor.
And it begins in how
our body responds to the
things that we think about.
And if you think depressive things,
your body, your energy becomes depressed.
If you're thinking negative things,
can you smile and laugh and tell jokes and
go run around in circles with children and
play and dance?
You can't do it, because
you've got depressive thoughts.
And if you're really (beep) excited,
can you help yourself?
Like if someone tells you
you need to sit down and
shut up and bottle it
all in, but you're like,
"It's the night before
Christmas.", like a little kid.
Tell a little kid to sit
down during like Christmas,
well put Christmas presents
or birthday presents in
front of them and say, "Sit there.".
They can't help it, the
excitements going to burst out.
So your body responds to your thoughts.
What's going on is going
to show up in your body.
And this is just my reiteration of the
fact that the body is the mind
and we begin with the body.
Now how do we control the
thoughts coming in and
out of our heads?
Negative thoughts that
you now a victim of,
because the thoughts are victimizing you.
They come in like a
virus and they take over,
just like any other pathogen.
You get a stomach bug and it gets in you,
and that's it, you're fucked.
Until you take some
medicine to get it out.
Well, thoughts are an interesting thing,
because like I eluded to before,
we have to entertain them in order for
them to have any power.
Now consider this term 'entertain'.
Someone comes to your door.
You're mom, you haven't seen
your mom in a very long time or
an old friend comes to the door.
Your old friend comes to the
door and you invite him into
your house, and now what do you do?
You entertain.
You offer energy in his direction.
Hey, would you like something to drink.
Sure.
Hey, have a seat.
This is my favorite chair,
I'd like you to try it out.
Hey, check it out when you lean it back,
you see how comfortable that is?
Oh, I'll call my wife.
Colleen, some of that dip
that you made last night,
do you have any of that left?
We'd like to entertain our
friend with some nourishing food.
What kind of movies do you like?
I've got a whole DVD collection.
People don't have DVD collections anymore,
we have Netflix and Hulu.
Have you seen that movie yet?
Let's sit down and watch it.
And by the way, let's have
a beer while we watch it.
That's entertaining someone
who comes into your home.
A friendly who you'd like
to have around for a while,
and allow them to grow roots for a moment.
There are certain thoughts
that make their way into
the home of your consciousness.
They knock on the door.
Your first choice is
to either let them in.
I mean, before entertaining,
you got to let it in.
Let the thought it or close
the door, slam the door shut.
The way that looks is,
I get negative thoughts.
Elliott Hulse gets negative thoughts.
Negative (beep) comes into my life,
sometimes the weirdest (beep) things.
It's like, I really don't know
why this keeps popping up.
Here's one, I keep having this one.
That I'm going to get into a car accident.
I don't know why, it's a new one.
But I keep thinking
that I'm not going to be
paying attention while
I'm driving and my car is
going to (mimmicks
crashing sound) demolish.
For whatever reason that
keeps knocking at my door.
Maybe I should pay attention to it.
I wear my seatbelt,
maybe that's what it is,
it's a warning.
Buckle your (beep) seatbelt
and don't check your
phone while you're driving.
Take heed.
But I don't let it in such that
I start obsessing over car accidents or
I become a nervous (beep)
wreck while I'm driving.
I don't start watching
videos about car wrecks and
on the news when there's
a car accident, I start,
(gasps) that could've been me.
I don't entertain the
thought, I don't go home and
start talking about car wrecks
and potential for dying in
a car accident with my
wife and my friends,
because I'm not entertaining the thought.
He came to the door, I peaked, I said,
"Oh (beep)!", and I
walked away, he goes away.
Now sometimes, often times,
because I attract them,
beautiful thoughts come in
like goals I'd like to achieve.
You know what I'd like one day?
Not because I need it,
not because I'm greedy,
not for anything but the
fact that I know I can do it.
I want one of those Mercedes G Classes.
That's a six figure car.
It looks like a jeep, but I
don't have to have this thing,
I'm not making myself neurotic.
But it's a nice thought that
when it comes to my window,
I say, "Come on in.",
and I look at pictures.
I go on the internet,
see how much it costs,
and I drive by the Mercedes dealership and
I see it in there.
And then one day I might go
in there and I might sit in
there and say, "Look sir, I
can't afford one of these,
"but boy I'd like to sit in it.".
Because I'm entertaining the thought.
Guess what?
I'm smiling, my body feels good.
I'm receptive to it.
Watch my video long enough,
I'll tell you when I have it.
And I won't have to break my ass for it,
because it happens just
by entertaining it.
Pain is a beautiful thing.
Challenge is what life's about.
A life without challenge,
a life without pain,
is a life without growth.
And where there is no
growth, there is stale,
stagnant energy, and that's
where most people live.
Because most people's
lives are designed around
treading a path that is void of challenge.
The minute they recognize
challenge or pain,
they move the other way.
This is a primal instinct
and normal and natural,
but a weak perspective.
Most people are bored if you ask them.
What do you think about your life?
"(sighs) Same old, same old.".
Every single day, same say,
same (beep), different day
things of this nature.
That's because they're
living their lives in
a lie that is shrouded in
comfort, it doesn't exist.
They're not challenged,
they're not growing,
they're bored and they're better off dead.
Your aliveness is found in your pain.
Embrace it, love it, and grow from it.
I knew being the king of
everything Elliot Hulse,
my health had to be right.
I'm not the king of everything
if my health is not right.
My health is priority more than
family dawg, relationships, love.
Not all you guys have
family, but i knew that when
my dad challenged me with,
"You can't be everything.",
one of the challenges
was, oh you want to be
a business owner, you
want to be a entrepreneur,
you want to be a tough guy,
you want to go out there and
succeed and make a lot of money,
but make sure that you
take care of your family.
Because if you take care of
all that other (beep) and
your family is not taken
care of, then you're a loser,
you're a fake, you're
foogazey, you're falling short,
and you ain't making it happen like
a true king of everything.
So I knew right away that if I'm
going to design this business,
alright that's third, we'll
talk about it in minute.
But if I was to design
my lifestyle in general,
let's begin with what we have, health.
Number one.
Then I have to fit it around
and I have to work it with and
it has to dance amongst
things like family.
Pick out some boy builders you know,
pick out some power lifters you know,
pick out any obsessed
athlete that you know,
and look at their family.
If they can balance their family and
their family's well taken care
of, the wife is satisfied and
the children are respectful,
then what you have on your
hands ladies and gentlemen
is the making of a king.
Today we got this fun, interesting
question from my buddy,
19 years old, he just started working out,
he's eating right, starting
to "Feel his body" is the
way he describes it.
And he's excited about
the progress he's making,
but one thing that he's
noticed is that because
he's getting up earlier
and he's exercising and
exerting himself in
that way, he finds that
about halfway through
the day, he gets tired.
And of course, it's kind of normal.
You're doing more, so your body's going to
require more cultivation, and
that's fine, somewhat natural.
The thing is he said that he
discovered something really
interesting, or he had an experience and
he's wondering, "Is this real?".
He says, "I got done
with my workout one day",
and he says, "earlier
this week I got done with
"my workout, I figured I'd go home and
"I'm pretty tired like
I typically am after a
"long day of becoming the
strongest version of myself.
"And on my way out I
noticed a really hot chick.
"I said to myself, 'You know what,
"'I'm feeling pretty damn confident.
"'I'm going to go and
introduce myself to her.".
He goes and introduces
himself to this hot girl on
his way out of the gym, and he says it was
a complete mess.
Completely fell apart,
he tried his best but
she wasn't interested.
But it didn't matter because he
discovered something even more important.
He said, "I was more energized
for the rest of that day than
"I can remember ever being energized.
"Normally I'd be tired, but
after subjecting myself to
"this dangerous experience,
by being courageous with
"this young girl, I was animated
for the rest of the day,
"I had more energy than
ever before, Elliot.".
So let me give you the
specific question towards the
end of this email.
He says, "Do you believe that
doing things you're afraid to
"do makes you feel more
alive and gives you energy?".
Well my friend, you've stumbled
upon a central principle of
all these videos I create.
And a lot of people think I'm
completely irresponsible and
out of my mind and nuts
when I tell young men to
go and do dangerous
(beep), to trust in the
most dangerous things
and trust your heart,
and your heart drew you towards this girl.
And what was the experience?
A complete (beep) mess.
Guess what?
Most of the time when
you're courageous enough to
follow your heart, in the
beginning and perhaps for
quite some time, it's going
to be a complete (beep) mess.
I know this, that's why I often say,
you don't take the call to adventure,
you don't follow your heart,
you don't do the thing that
your body is telling you to do because of
what you're going to get.
You do it because of who
you're going to become.
Right, my friend?
And who did you become
after experiencing that
dangerous moment, by
subjecting yourself to that
experience that was dangerous?
Because mind you, stress
is stress regardless.
There's going to be a
physiological response in
your body to stress regardless.
If it's you're jumping
out of a helicopter or
you're talking to a hot girl.
What kind of person were you afterwards?
Animated.
You were more vibrant,
vital, alive, energetic,
ready to go.
You're becoming a stronger
version of yourself because
of that and what happens is that
the stress is a unique type of stress,
and I've heard it described this way.
Of course there's stress and there's a
physiological response to stress,
but there's a different color
to distress and eu-stress.
Now I don't know if eu-stress,
eu-stress is an actual word,
but the person who shared
it with me was trying to
combine the term 'euphoric',
euphoric with stress, eu-stress.
Distress is a kind of
nagging, chronic stress where
you're constantly
anxious because you can't
pay your bills or you'll
never get the career that
you want or you'll never live up to
your daddy's expectations.
And you go about life with
this nagging distress that
ultimately leads to your demise.
It just stresses you out,
it grows you older and
more degenerated over time.
That's the stress that
most people deal with.
Eu-stress is a completely
different phenomena.
There's a physiological
response in your body,
which is sympathetic, that's
why you felt so energetic.
But it's colored with euphoria because
of what you're becoming.
You just exercised what I
believe to be the iron quality of
becoming the strongest
version of yourself,
and that is courage.
And the experience was a complete mess,
but you're growing.
You see, this distress
makes you sick and dying.
Eu-stress creates growth,
and that's why I often say,
go do dangerous (beep).
Not because Elliot Hulse is a
douche bag and he's trying to
give bad advice to young men.
But because I know that when
you jump off that cliff and
your only intention is
to fly before you hit the
(beep) bottom, you're
going to animate all your
vital resources to learn
how to fly on the way down.
And that's why you have to jump.
You know there's a different
type of response to
that cliff that a lot of
people, most people, experience.
And that is they stare
down that cliff their
entire lives until they're like 40, 45,
50 and they got what you
call this midlife crisis.
This is when you've committed
to all of the trappings.
There's that word 'trappings', trappings.
Traps of the world.
You've got a family,
you've got a business,
you've got a career, you've got a boss,
you've got taxes.
Now you can't jump dude,
because you're too trapped by
the trappings of the world.
Now in my book, I say you still jump.
But anyway, the point is,
if you stand there and
you just keep looking
down into that chasm,
you reach the edge of that
cliff when you're 25 years old,
guess what you're going to live
with for the next 25 years?
Distress that kills you,
because you didn't jump.
There's that part of you
that's always tapping you,
"Hey dude, (beep), I told
you to jump 20 years ago,
"you still didn't jump did you?
"How do you feel about yourself?".
Well I've got $100,000 in my bank account.
Man, who gives a (beep)?
My wife's hot.
Who gives a (beep)?
I've got children to take care of.
You should've jumped when
I told you to jump and
now you got to live with it.
Thank you so much for watching.
- We made this video because
captain awesome asked us to.
Now if you have a famous
entrepreneur you would
like profiled, leave a comment below.
- I'd also love to know which of
Elliot's top 10 rules hit you the hardest.
Leave in the comments below,
we'll join the discussion.
Thank you so much for watching.
Continue to believe,
and we'll see you soon.
- Sometimes you got to
do the things that aren't
necessarily lined with your core values to
get you to where you're going.
And I don't mean that you
got to lie, cheat, and steal.
But to balance your four
directions like I often talk about,
you use the sharpened
intelligence, deepened intuition,
expanding love, and
your aggressive action.
Sometimes, especially in
the beginning stages of
trying to get the ball rolling,
aggressive action just takes everything.
Often time it becomes...
You're a magician and you're a warrior,
love gets set aside and order
often gets set aside because
you're doing what you have
to do to get (beep) done.
As the ball begins rolling,
as you start gaining a
level of success, come
back to your core values,
why you began in the beginning.
Often times we make our
passions our business.
And you mentioned yesterday,
it might not be a good idea,
because what happens
then is the thing that
you once loved now becomes a job, right?
And that's when the petition
as a warrior completely just in
an imbalanced way, taking
things to where it needs to
go so that there's some sort of movement.
But once the ball is rolling,
step back for a moment.
This has just been my experience,
come back to your core values
and why you're doing the
thing that you're doing,
fall back in love with it.
Because there's a tendency
to fall out of love with
it when it becomes your business.
An then start proceeding from that place.
It brings the love back into your world.
Your conviction matters far
more than what you do or
even what your idea is.
To be a tremendous means
that you first lead yourself.
Become fully enrolled in
strengthening your conviction in
whatever it is that you choose.
And then the method just happens.
You don't have to follow
a step by step formula.
You don't have to grab and control,
although that is a method.
You've got a Jesus or a
Mohammed, Jesus flips tables and
tells you, "Come, follow me.".
Mohammed goes in and
breaks all the statues,
tells you what to think.
And you've got a Buddha,
who sits under a tree and
waits for you to come,
equally convinced that
their ideal is the one.
So to cut to the chase,
grow your strength of conviction and
the path toward leadership
will be unveiled.
Don't copy or follow
in anyone's footsteps.
Strengthen your own feet
and stomp your own ground.
Don't be afraid to
fail, get out there and,
my invitation is always, go
and experience life instead of
reading about it.
Go and experience life instead
of asking someone else to
tell you how to live life.
Go out there and fail, go out
there and scrape your knees,
go out there and do the wrong thing.
That way you now have an
experience that adds to the
tool to support you in
the building of your life.
Everybody wants, we as
individuals and as parents and
as a world abound, respects
insurance and security and
safety to such a great
degree it does not afford you
the power of your own
subject of experience.
My invitation is always
to ignore everyone and
try for yourself, trust
yourself, believe in yourself.
Go out there and be all that
you can be regardless of
what anyone else has to say about it,
because people are
trying to keep you down,
they want you to stay in
that little category that
they created for you.
And you've got to transcend that,
you've got to trust yourself.
Courage is the virtue that
allows that to happen,
so be courageous.